Speaker 1: All right. Let's get into the Friday
mailbag. Info at David Pakman dot com for
questions, comments, concerns, suggestions, all
of it. And of course, occasionally a tweet or a
Facebook message or a YouTube comment might make
it into this segment. We love all of it. Let's
start today with some criticisms, some criticisms
which I am. I'm glad to issue corrections when I
make mistakes. I'm glad to give a sampling of
comments from people that aren't thrilled with
me. David wrote in and said, You were out there,
dude. Trump was and maybe will be again the best
thing that's happened to this country in decades.
Open your eyes. Your radio cast must be funded by
the Democrats. No, the Democrats and the demon
rats and the Democrats. None of them fund the
show. George Soros doesn't fund the show. Whoever
else you imagine is funding the show doesn't
fund the show. The show is funded mostly by our
audience and then by a few advertisers. That's
that's kind of what it is. The I guess all I can
say is congratulations for using the correct your
the correct form of your. All right. So David is
waiting around for the return of Trump almost in,
like, a weird, messianic way. It's very, very
interesting. Next criticism is from Don. Don
wrote in and said, You are a freak, an idiot. Take
your liberal Marxist socialistic garbage somewhere
else. It's idiots like you that are destroying
this country. The oligarchies are bringing this.
That's oligarchy. Apostrophe S are bringing
this country down and should they succeed,
you won't mean crap to them. Then let's
see how you will put food on your table,
pay your mortgage and charge your defunct
grid system car you don't know crap and are
just as stupid as the rest of your Democratic
constituents. Well, a really strong condemnation
by Don of a political ideology that I don't
hold. I'm not a marxist or a socialist,
but maybe go find a marxist or a socialist and
criticize them. I don't know. It's always weird.
They seem confused. Matt wrote in about interviews
with the so-called radical left. Matt says, David,
sir, just listen to your explanation of how right
wing candidates may or may not end up on your show
for interviews. And it made me wonder if there are
any left wing candidates that you might consider
radical or unreasonable in some of their views.
And if you'd be interested in interviewing them,
perhaps there aren't any. And it is purely a
disease of the Republican Party. I wouldn't be
surprised, but I'd be interested in your take
either way. Yeah, I mean, listen, there are
extreme leftists. The difference is the extreme
leftists don't ever seem to win their Democratic
primaries. And one of the things we do on this
show, because we can't turn the show into the,
you know, ninth Congressional District Show
where we interview everybody running for the
Democratic nomination and everybody running for
the Republican nomination. We tend to wait until
after primaries to do these interviews as a
practical matter. And the Republicans will
often vote for the wackiest in the primary. And
so that's who I end up interviewing. Democrats
rarely vote for the super wacky, extreme left
winger. And so by the time they get to me,
there's been a sorting already. And much the same
way that Trump would never have won the Democratic
primary in 2016. A lot of the so-called radical
left that Matt is referring to in his email
don't pass that first filter. And that's why they
don't end up on the show. But I've no opposition
in principle to speaking to anybody. Robert wrote.
And this is very interesting and this relates to
Roe v Wade and abortion and other things we've
been talking about, Roberts says. Big fan of
the show. Appreciate your rational approach to
controversial subjects. I wanted to write to
you about abortion. People are unfortunately, but
legally making end of life decisions all the time.
When an individual's higher brain function ceases,
the family can opt to have life support suspended.
This is generally rationalized by the collective
understanding that once higher brain functions
have ended, the person is already gone. If people
have accepted and this is the wrong accepted. So
the right word here is Assisi. This is that. But
let's imagine we understand what Robert is saying.
If people have accepted that this is the way
things are, then why can't the opposite be true?
If your life ends when your higher brain function
stops, then why would your beginning of life be
before your higher frame brain function begins?
My understanding is that dreaming is supposed to
begin in the third trimester. If I'm not mistaken,
this should signify the beginnings of thought and
the brain's need to process them. So there's
a couple issues here. First of all, Robert is
completely correct, and there's actually another
aspect to this. Which is. Quote, Other people
make decisions about end of life all the time, as
you're talking about in situations where people's
brain function has stopped or in lots of different
situations, including hospice type situations.
Why couldn't the same decisions be made when
a fetus has no brain function and isn't going
to do so? In these most extreme cases where
Republicans want women carrying non-viable fetuses
to term, why is it okay to make those decisions
for others later and not earlier? Aside from
the personhood question, but there's kind of a
bigger issue here, which is you're never going to
convince the right on abortion with arguments like
this because they will say, well, we don't care
about brain function, we care about heartbeat. And
that's where the heartbeat bills come from. And
then you'd say, Well, okay, but what about this?
And they'll say, Now we believe life begins at
conception and it's an endless loop. And so while
these types of questions that Robert brings up are
super interesting and they're accurate and the
relevant, that's not going to convince the most
ardent anti-choicers on the right. Sadly, I wish
we could talk sense with them, but unfortunately
we can't. Sean wrote in about my interview with
that Republican candidate, Alison Haden, who's
running against our friend Eric Swalwell. And Sean
says to David or whomever, whomever. I enjoy all
of David's interviews. I find them fascinating
and informative. But I think my favorite type of
interview is when David speaks to Republicans who
seem to be confused by facts versus their opinion.
Needless to say, I was glued to your discussion
with Alison Haden. As per the usual, I think
David did a great job. But there's one question
I would love to hear him ask of these people.
If Trump would have won the presidency, would
they still be making such a big deal out of the
legitimacy and security of our elections? Guys, we
all know the answer to that. Of course they would
if Trump had won the electoral vote or the
electoral vote and the popular vote. They would be
doing what they did in 2016, which is saying sort
of like there was some fraud. And my real victory
was even bigger. But they would not be filing
60, 70 court complaints. Of course, they wouldn't
be doing any of those things. Don't believe
for a second that this is some kind of moral
fight for them. It's just about their guy lost.
That's all they care about. Danielle wrote in
about my Republican guests and says, David, after
hearing your interview yesterday with the Northern
California Republican candidate, that was Alice
in head. And after hearing several other recent
videos, interviews, I have an honest inquiry
as to whether you seek out the worst Republican
candidates to interview or if you're just shooting
fish in a barrel. Do you specifically target the
crazies or are you just giving us a sampling of
what the Republican Party has generally become?
Love You're taking them to task, though, and
trying desperately to make them think about the
word salad they're spewing. So. Last week we had a
voicemail asking a similar question. My colleague
John has been heading up these interviews. He has
interviewed, I want to say, close to 50 different
Republican candidates. Some of them don't even
respond. Some of them do. But then they find out
about how interviews are conducted here and that
real questions will be asked. And then they say,
I'm not interested or they stop responding. Some
will agree to come on. And then once we schedule
it, we'll never hear from them again. Some
confirmed the interview literally hours before
it's scheduled, and then they just never show
up on Skype and we never hear from them again.
We cast a wide net. Some of them are less crazy
like that guy Johnny Teague I interviewed. I still
disagree with him about just about everything, but
he was less overtly bonkers and less cuckoo for
Cocoa Puffs. But we are casting a wide net. We're
not targeting the whack jobs, but a lot of them
are really wacky and it's just a representation
of who's running in that party right now.
I the zombie all. Wrote in and said, David, you
should sit back and think about why right wingers
around the world are performing better than ever.
People are very angry at their politicians. Yeah,
it's I think the implication here is the left
has done so terribly that globally and really
they mean like Western Europe and to some degree
the Americas. Voters are going to right wingers.
What's going on is that parties on both sides
anecdotally have failed the voters in lots of
parts of the world. But the real change has
been the echo chambers created by social media
and modern media, which allow really stupid, quite
frankly, ideas primarily on the non-science right
to get repetition that they wouldn't otherwise
get. We've talked before. If Nixon had had Fox
News and Facebook, it's not clear Nixon would have
actually ended up resigning, and it's possible he
would have been impeached by the House and maybe
not convicted by the Senate. If Senators at that
time had seen support in social media the way
there was support for Trump during the impeachment
trials that he had. So I do think that a lot of
this is thanks to disinformation, faux populist
messages, or maybe actual populist messages, which
don't really lead to any substantive policy, have
also kind of infected the political discussion.
And so it's not about the left has been so bad
that right wingers have won that it's not that
at all. But there is a story there to be told,
and I think it's an important one for sure.
All right. If you have any questions, comments,
concerns, things you want to say, write to info at
David Pakman dot com. Your email may be featured
on an upcoming episode. And remember that the
party doesn't have to end right now. You can sign
up on my website, join Packman dot com to get an
extra show every day. That's the bonus show and so
many more great member benefits. You can use the
coupon code, indict i and d i c t to save a bundle
off of the cost of a membership. We'll see you on
the bonus show or otherwise got here on monday.